[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci jean luc alors jean-luc qu'est ce
que tu me donnes tout ça avant moi je
suis au cp3 danser p3l iii et iv [ __ ]
j'aimerais être pas comme toi y avait
une petite estrade pour les enfants
attends je vais bouger moncube merci
bougeait bien votre cube allez on y va
alors là si on peut plus parler
géométrie alors vous voulez une question
peut-être aviation pour une question les
quatre tiers jean luc qui regarde tout
ce qui se passe en coulisses dans cette
émission et même pendant l'émission lui
voit des trucs je le dis à chaque fois
qu'on ne voit pas que personne ne voit
ici exactement et j'ai une question pour
vous bonjour je m'appelle michel on dit
souvent que l'équipe de tpm paix c'est
une famille donc je voulais savoir est
ce que comme dans une famille normale
tout le monde se déteste bon a priori
michel était dans la même école de
théâtre que gilles verdez à tout le
monde déteste déteste pas dans l'équipe
nous sommes une vraie famille mais nous
sommes avant tout des professionnels
choisis pour nos compétences dans les
médias et d'ailleurs on avait pu le
vérifier lors du jeu c'est qui le patron
ou syrie n'avait eu la bonne idée de
comparer nos connaissances à celle d'un
ancien stagiaire de la prod galles
patron qui va arriver justement après
vous avez fait de bonnes réponses
autant dire que vous êtes nuls à chier
et vous êtes nuls on n'est pas bien dur
à jouer ensemble
jean-michel ça fait longtemps qu'il a
renoncé à faire semblant il connaît rien
et il est content mais il faut pas le
juger trop durement parce que il faut
s'arrête aux depuis le départ de thierry
l'ait perdu ils avaient des habitudes
des échanges complices ses mains et
florent secrètement les cuisses de titi
maintenant à la place il ya maxime
guinea c'est un autre délire 1 ça ça se
passe bien mais c'est autre chose c'est
très étonnant
les deux discutent beaucoup ensemble
enfin surtout maxime on sait ce qu'on
perd on sait quoi comme quoi le départ
de débits annoncés sont de bonnes
nouvelles
c'est pourquoi mathieu dit finalement
mais je suis pas d'accord c'est une très
très bonne nouvelle l'arrivée de maxime
non mais c'est vrai franchement merci
parce que ça a demandé une touche de
jeunesse est de savoir dans l'émission
et et c'est bien jean michel un camp
quand il connaît pas une référence un
peu jones c'est une de mes vidéos
préférées de la semaine regardez bien ça
allez c'est parti
vous allez voir en fait le gars
maintenant se prend pour pnl benjamin
biolay
[Musique]
l'ars
[Applaudissements]
canal+ depuis il se garde freinet et
nous regardent souvent on avait perdu
il sera possible et le moi j'adore aussi
la réaction d un groupe de 1 à gâter un
peu sous les restes à un groupe de rap
et dire que c'est les jeunes de
l'émission un vrai cette séquence aurait
eu sa place dans le top gênante voilà
vous savez ces petites séquences un
petit peu courtes comme ça un peu
gênante mais désolé j'avais encore pire
que ça c'est top chénens la mana c'est
mon moment préféré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle vous l'écoutez s'agit du coup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui millions entre les analystes le
pouvoir en place
et puis et le pouvoir en place ok
[Musique]
mais ce qu'ils disent j'essaye de
surtitré mais là je pouvais pas le guide
pour vous franchement j'ai on a cherché
longtemps un sommet pour rien de ce
qu'ils disent c'est alors qu'est ce qui
te signal
[Musique]
c'est dieu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aux visions entre les journalistes et le
pouvoir en place
et puis au pouvoir ok
mais c'est ma du trajet aller et les
quais mort de rire eric il adore les
quatre tiers eric et voit la boucherie
bonne nouvelle d'ailleurs pour l'avenir
du top gênante la semaine dernière cyril
annoncé que j'aurais bientôt jean michel
et être le nouveau bachelor si ça c'est
quand même une belle promesse de
bêtisiers et d'ailleurs je voudrais
rendre hommage à lily delahaye la
profileuse ah oui qui nous avait dit une
chose improbable il ya quelques semaines
on s'en rappelle c'est vrai c'est vrai
nom alors jean-michel c'est j'ai plutôt
enfin dans deux ans et va demander en
mariage une femme oui mais c'est un
scoop à saissac des bonnes nouvelles
non mais ça il fallait d'imaginer la
maternité elle avait senti que l'avenir
sentimental de jean-michel c'est un
mariage moi à l'époque j'aurais plus
miser sur une mycose
[Rires]
donc jean michel seurat vous l'avez dit
le no 20 c'est fou c'est fou et dans
l'équipe je vais vous dire la vérité on
est tous très excités par le projet j'ai
chopé une conversation
[Musique]
et de s'interroger
sur mesure
il croit en vous dans l'équipe j'avais
beaucoup sur moi mais c'est vrai que
j'ai un fardeau sur les épaules
pire pour vous benjamin mathieu
delormeau animateurs ou jean-michel je
me passe alors à c'est incontestablement
de leurs mots animateur c'est bien s'il
serait bien non on est rendus à leur
mercie benayoun et abbas et jean mis en
bâchant pour moi le bachelor ça le
bachelor c'est la beauté c'est là
magnifique genre depuis le début c'est
que des gogos
moi je kiffe man jean-mi enfin messi est
vide et peut-être il va se révéler être
révélées non là je pense pas ce cachet
d'origine dire la porte
on rappelle le pratique du bachelor
c'est un garçon qui est très riche très
beau et qui est célibataire et qui est
très jeune et une excellente donne donc
les riches voilà jeunes beaux et riches
à wallers l'amour donc franchement vous
savez trouve hardy alors là pour le coup
là pour le coup on peut parler de
jean-michel à peu près la nouvelle
candidature d'ailleurs de quoi de
famille saadé candidature vous aversion
prêtres dont on va recevoir voulez-vous
cadran pour aller voir une surprise
allez pour mettre une bonne ambiance
dans l'équipe je vous propose d'envoyer
tous mes camarades au bistrot ces
principes ont ralenti les images et
malheureusement tout le monde al'air
bourg et on adore
[Musique]
oui on a fait là on a fait la théorie de
la danish en cinéma seul barrage et
dénicheur allez vous les gars sont en
forme
le pari est donc venez vous vider un
meuble et on nous a sauté aux yeux vides
et un beau but non j'en oublie d vous
allez libère les droites le break et le
gars me dit menacé pas non et je dis
mais si je t'avais menacée si je t'avais
menacée tu serais pas là devant moi
[Musique]
beaucoup des gens et ne l'est pas ce
moyen
maxime dillies plus que certains
courageux françois
ao à huy jour même d'une photo qui est à
ma femme avec avec un ami sa femme et un
autre ami le et et sa femme pour c'est
fini philippe les olives réseau livre
oui les olives
oui quoi et des olives oui je crois
qu'ils m'ont
[Musique]
aux saluts
il est bien vrai ça marche bien qu'on
leur a menti et jean-luc magnifique bon
jusqu'à présent j'ai montré des choses
peu glorieuse de la vie de l'équipe
alors pour contrebalancer vraiment
entrer maintenant un geste tendre un
geste tendre quand il n'aura profite
d'un d'un face à face vous savez le
face-à-face corps va d'un côté ou de
l'autre de la table et elle en a profité
pour casser le dos de maxime gainey
dernière donc apprécier mais pas droit
[Musique]
tu crois y avait bien sûr des
possesseurs
j'adore mais ce qui est bien c'est que
les fans avec sim c'est le seul mec
qu'on lui fait une vanne qui prend tous
au premier degré regardez la suite les
gars du public vont me dire qu'il a une
belle veste
ouais lui l'hyper fait que c'est un vrai
compliment mon passage préféré c'est
quand il va appeler et n'aura pour
l'engueuler ça c'est le temps du papa
qui s'énerve quand sa petite veut pas
ranger sa chambre
c'est quoi ça
j'avais pas les sauvegarder pas les
sentiers d'ouvrir la famille non
autre chouchou jana j'aime bien on
discute beaucoup par sms est ya une
connexion entre nous mais surtout quand
tu y crois que suis agathe
je suis moi même on discute beaucoup
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai mon
chien je vais vous dire qu'après le ça
va pas la tête
enora l'a compris à qui il avait affaire
a eu peur en tout cas maintenant maxime
c'est que ce que nous on savait tous
depuis longtemps et n'aura plus créer
galets saisies dans le dos ou zizi sur
ardoise maxime qui a fait aussi beaucoup
de bien à l'émission avec son expertise
média ah oui vous allez voir isabelle et
benjamin sont subjugués par ses analyses
et ses scoops tarbes le clash générateur
d'audience lorsque vous voyez les
courbes généralement ça monte à chaque
fois et là il ya vraiment 3,5 régnante
qui sont importants
clash rime avec cash et vous mettez
amour avec des illusions et là vous avez
tout ce qu'il faut pour faire une bonne
série réalité
et bien parce que
c'est bien parce que maxime minutes a
expliqué la télé réalité comme un oui ma
vie alma est la candidate de
l'eurovision il a plus recherchés sur
internet un très bonne réponse
[Applaudissements]
je vais aller à l'entourage de quelques
imitateur et c'est vrai que l'avoine de
emmanuel macron est très compliqué parce
qu'il n'a pas donné de gymnich de
tendance de dato nation particulière
donc descendu comment ça fait cette
semaine un dans le magazine la santé
vingt ans 19 ans déjà les prochaines way
we had enough ça fait presque il est
vrai que vu cette semaine s'il enchaîne
beaucoup de magazines de la santé allô
docteurs les enquêtes senti une fois par
mois sur france 5 sur france 2 il fait
des enquêtes de médecine sur w9 il n'y a
pas de garçons actuellement je pense
qu'il faudrait non mais c'est vrai on va
passagers pas vous mouiller la comprenne
c'est vrai c'est 8 c à linars bah voilà
passons et non pas deux visages
masculins
cette année ça c'est moyennement passé
je ne sais pas
bonjour
lorient 6 6
récit
je savais pas parce que vous n'avez plus
droit y êtes vous bien sûr
alors vous vous êtes parce que vous êtes
le remplaçant et presse à une oreillette
vous ne riez pas ce que s'il ya des des
informations de dernière minute des
compléments d'information ou par exemple
pendant une homogénéité visuelle quand
tout le monde lève sa pancarte pour
qu'ils soient plus beau allait
occasionner vous si vous d'être le
remplaçant 6 miles away je gère aussi je
vais être honnête avec le mexique
puisque je suis honnête
moi aussi j'ai pas parfois la lourde
tâche de les cadrer pour l'ailé pas la
vache à lait et voudrait dire que le
cadre est quelqu'un et on choisit toi
ouais c'est ça vous n'avez pas nous
c'est la maxime qui cadrent ce côté-là
et benjamins qui annoncera l'envoi des
sms mais son arbre ah oui d'accord sur
ce thème ottawa non c'est méchant de
dire en tout cas que tout lui souffle
dans l'oreillette
oui mais bon donc cgem l'objectivité
j'ai mené mon enquête ah je me suis
prospérer qu'il avait une oreillette moi
je fais ça je me suis procuré la piste
sont de l'oreillette à ohlala donc ça
s'il avait raison mais les images sur
lui édifiant ça va tomber
maxime coup concentre toi alors
attention à 3 tu rigoles c'était dur
puis débrouille très bien mais attention
là on va enchaîner vire applause et
commentaires que deux personnes entendra
alors je veux de la dent blanche
aléatoire
perso à demain
et c'est drôle
maggie q j'adore je reconnais presque
l'avoir presque
[Rires]
il est temps de passer à tous qu'on n'en
avait pas voulu voir et entendre dans
l'émission on commence par le coup de
pression la semaine et ça se passait
dans le public ça peut tomber sur vous
la prochaine fois vous allez voir sur un
jingle un garçon va se lever pour danser
ça va pas plaire du tout à sa copine qui
va le calmer direct on voit qui est la
patronne fait partie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu as quel âge tu as mon chéri 6 6 ans
avant que nous en sommes à gâteaux pour
ou alors mal et des retenues 1 à dire
est qu'elle va jouer dans au pays de
candy
j'aime bien alors dentelle je sais mais
bon c'est sûr son appel d'offres
qu'est-ce qui sait le problème c'est
sympa mais j'ai tellement le trac
j'arrive pas à excuser moi même j'ai un
sens de faire ma première émission
ah oui c'est la dernière petite carrière
en allemagne
d'autres petits cailloux une femme tous
n'ont donc voila quoi en santé oui bah
oui quoi l'egypte et pourquoi
l'allemagne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sortie
toi
daniel moreau qu'est ce que je vous ai
dit en loge tout à l'heure encore une
fois
[Musique]
ils y arrivent même à détrôner jetro
jusqu'à la cale aux tirs et 9
bédard
[Applaudissements]
jean luc lemoine